let's go to uh manfred from hong kong
manfred from hong kong you were on the
air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
um so i was just wondering
um what the relationship between and
china
and u.s would become under
yeah by them i think you're going to see
um a lot of the trade war aspects
dealt with although you know we have to
understand that at this point china is
likely to sort of
want to negotiate on the uh
removal of tariffs because
what donald trump did is crazy so i
don't you know there are some who think
it will be as simple as joe biden being
sworn in
and then saying to china let's get rid
of all those tariffs
i don't think it's going to be that that
easy and i understand why
uh but i do think that jo you know joe
biden is someone
who understands much more about china
than donald trump will ever hope to and
i'm hoping for a normalization of
relations
yeah the other question i have
is um throughout the campaign joe biden
always said that he wants unity
and judging from his cabinet
like do you think he achieved
that goal well listen this is a
beautiful question manfred i i really
appreciate it
um joe biden is not going to pick right
wingers
to his cabinet by and large right so
most of the picks i think are very
reasonable people like as an example
janet yellen janet yellen is a left-wing
economist but she is
eminently qualified she's an academic
a scholar she's not going to do anything
crazy nothing that she would support
would be
socialism she's a very reasonable
selection
now uh nira tandon who joe biden
selected
the left the the progressive left and
many on the right
dislike niro tandon i think it's the
opposite of unity i think that pick was
a disaster so i think there's a lot of
this and a lot of that with the
selections that joe biden has made so
far
um so overall what do you think
overall i think that joe biden's
selections
have mostly been of course people on the
left
center left and as much as one could
expect republicans to be okay with that
they they have not been controversial
selections in any way
oh yeah so thanks for having me
yeah of course so man so you're how
how are things in hong kong right now
um it's been fine
um there are a little bit search
in cover cases yeah yeah overall it's
been fine
[Music]
we tried to get the local cases down to
zero but we just can't do it
got it got it and and have you been
listening to the show watching the show
for a while
yeah um about
august i think since august okay yeah
well manfred i really appreciate it
you're the first caller we've had from
hong kong
yeah thanks for having me all right
manfred from hong kong what a call
what a call